welcome back president Trump has himself
a merry little Christmas Mitt Romney
decides to go after President Trump in
his first day on the job and Louie CK
gets clobbered by the social justice
warriors I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
well welcome back I hope that you had a
wonderful Christmas and wonderful New
Year's I know that I did and I could not
be more excited to be back here with you
I know sounds like I don't want to be
here but that's not true I actually do
want to be here I wanna be here with you
we're gonna get through this next year
together because it's going to be one
heck of a ride now we have a lot of news
to fill you in on a lot happened over
the last week and a half some of its
humorous some of it tragic there'll be
laughs there'll be smiles there will be
crying there will be tears there'll be a
lot going on in just a second but first
let's talk about the national debt 1.2
trillion dollars that's how much was
added to the national debt in fiscal
year 2018 economists say that by the end
of 2019 we will be spending more on the
interest on our national debt than we
spend on Medicare and by 2023 more than
we spend on the military as balloon
payments become do you should be asking
yourself what exactly is the impact on
the u.s. dollar going to be and what is
that impact going to be on your
investment so what's your plan can you
afford another hits your retirement like
the last day on turn when the S&P
dropped 50 percent can you really afford
the sort of volatility we've been seeing
in the stock market lately well a hedge
against inflation and a hedge against
uncertainty is precious metals gold is a
safe haven against uncertainty my
savings plan is diversified yours should
be 10 I mean take all your money out of
the stock market and dump it in gold I
mean take some of your money and put it
in precious metals it is responsible
should be diversified the company I
trust with precious metal purchases is
Birch gold group versus gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews and a plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
contact Birch gold group get a free
information kit on physical precious
metals see if diversifying into gold and
silver makes sense for you've got that
comprehensive 16 page kit shows how gold
and silver can protect your savings hey
can legally move your IRA or 401k
out of stocks and bonds into a precious
metals IRA if that's something you're
interested in to get that no-cost
no-obligation kit go to birchgold.com
slash been ask all your questions and
then get yourself some precious metal at
birchgold.com slash man go check them
out and start the new year off the
responsible way ok so it is a brand new
year and there's a lot of debate already
about what the 2019 is going to be 2018
part 2 the revenge or whether it's going
to be part 1 of 2020 pretty obviously
it's gonna be part 1 of 2020 because
everybody is already running for
president everybody is already trying to
figure out whether President Trump is
even going to stick around to run again
for president the answer is probably yes
but president Trump had himself a merry
little Christmas
he spent the Christmas of his life in
the White House by himself yeah
basically waiting out the government
shutdown and tweeting furiously from the
Oval Office so he had himself a lot of
fun he was there for Christmas he was
there for New Year's and that led him to
send out a bunch of tweets a bunch of
videos talking about what he's done so
far now all of that is is fine
the president has accomplished a great
many things in his first couple of years
in office remember he's only been in
office for a little under two years
which is incredible so for president
Trump it's sort of like there's Trump
ears and then there's regular years so
in regular years has only been like a
couple of years of president Trump's
presidency in Trump years it's been at
least 200 years of President Trump
presidency time has warped completely
President Trump is actually been
president since 1733 in regular years
but in Trump years he's only been
president for like two years so there's
that but President Trump listed his
historic accomplishments on New Year's
Eve in a little video that he cut for
Twitter here's what it sounded like I
just want to wish you a very very happy
new year it's going to be a great year
complicated but great but I will tell
you there has never been an
administration and I'm very proud of
this that's done more than the Trump
administration in the first two years of
office we've had a great two years I'm
working hard for you I'm fighting for
you we're gonna win we're gonna win all
the way we're gonna win it everything we
do so Happy New Year and let's enjoy the
next year and then we're gonna enjoy the
following year and then we have four
more and everything is going to be so
beautiful thank you very much have a
fantastic New Year
President Trump then tweeted out about
all of his accomplishments he said
listen everything's been great so far
you guys just don't appreciate you don't
appreciate it you don't know you don't
know anything it's been great I don't
know I didn't get it so you tweeted out
that everybody should calm down and
enjoy the ride he tweeted out in all
capital letters this was this is his
first tweet of the new year happy New
Year to everyone including the haters
and the fake news media 2019 will be a
fantastic years for those not suffering
from Trump derangement syndrome so calm
down and enjoy the ride all capital
letters great things are happening for
the country
nothing says to me calm down and enjoy
the ride like somebody tweeting that at
me in all capital letters I know that if
I'm in the back of the car and somebody
in the front of the car says calm down
and enjoy the ride nothing
is going to make me calm down and enjoy
the ride quite like that but yeah there
was this feeling of incipient panic that
was building up in the last days of 2018
and now it is carried forward into 2019
president Trump's furious tweets over
the break weren't not helpful
that way again the president has
accomplished a lot of things in his
first couple of years in office it's not
supremely helpful to be leading off his
reelection campaign with him kind of
hunkered down in the White House just
tweeting whatever comes into his mind
right now with the White House should be
projecting is a feeling of invincibility
a feeling of calm a feeling of collected
collected gold-making and shared purpose
and instead what we're sort of getting
is president Trump feeling isolated and
tweeting out a lot of things now a lot
of things he's tweeting are true by the
way so the president for example was
tweeting out a lot about the border
remember we're still in the middle of a
government shutdown that shutdown was
initiated by the Democrats there's been
a lot of talk about President Trump
initiating the shutdown because he was
foolish enough to claim on national
television that he wanted to own the
shutdown but in reality President Trump
did not really initiate the shutdown it
was the Democrats who initiated the
shutdown in the sense that they could
just give him five billion dollars for
his wall and then be done with it he
claimed victory they'd be able to go
home and sleep at night instead they've
decided to deny him that funding so this
led President Trump to tweet out a lot
about the border wall now this would be
a decent use of Twitter if it were not
for all of his other use of Twitter he
tweeted out president and mrs. Obama
built has a ten-foot wall around their
DC mansion in compound I agree totally
necessary for their safety and security
US needs the same same thing slightly
larger version okay well that's fine
everybody went nuts how dare president
Trump mentioned they have a wall around
their home as though that's a security
breach it's not a security breach okay
I've wall around my home most people
have some sort of fence around their
house especially in California but
President Trump then continued the
Democrats will probably submit a bill
being cute as always which gives
everything away but gives nothing to
border security namely the wall you see
without the border security without the
wall there can be no border security the
other stuff just is just by comparison
me is just by comparison meaningless
bells and whistles
remember this throughout the ages some
things never get better and never change
president Trump's we did you all you
have walls and you have wheels it was
always that way and it will always be
that way please explain to the Democrats
there can never be a replacement for a
good
old-fashioned wall first of all you can
have walls and you can have wheels and
you can have fire these are great
inventions of the past and President
Trump I can't wait to hear his his essay
on why the invention of fire was such a
useful thing but all of this is not
particularly terrible right the
president from going after the Democrats
on the wall stuff is not particularly
terrible it's just that the incessant
nature of it is not good politics and
this is going to become an issue for
president Trump come 2020 because when
it comes to the issues President Trump
has been pretty good as I've said many
times I did not expect him to govern
this conservatively when he was elected
in 2016 he is government far more
conservatively and I thought he was
going to with that said the character
flaws that the president has evidenced
are going to be the chief reason why
people are uncomfortable with him it's
got what's going to hurt him at the
polls it's what's going to alienate
people come 2020 it's that stuff yes to
get under control and it's also where
the Democrats are putting all their
heavy pressure they're putting all their
heavy pressure right now on the
character point leading that charge was
General Stanley McChrystal he's gonna be
on our Sunday special this week by the
way
general McChrystal was on ABC's this
week over the weekend and he basically
slammed president Trump's character here
he was talking with the very objective
journalist George Stephanopoulos I think
it's important for me to work for people
who I think are basically honest who
tell the truth as best they know it I
think he's a liar I don't think he tells
truth it's Trump amoral in your view I
think he is if we want to be governed by
someone we wouldn't do a business deal
with because they're their background is
so shady
if we're willing to do that then that's
in conflict with who I think we are so
there's what Cristal says with Martha
Raddatz on on ABC's this week going
after Trump's character now this is
always going to be from Achilles heel is
going to be the character point it has
been for a very long time and President
Trump has never been a guy of supreme
moral fiber shall we say and this was
one of his selling points in 2016 was
you don't have to worry about me pulling
my punches I'm not gonna pull my punches
I've never pulled my punches I'm not
that kind of guy
well he didn't pull his punches against
general McChrystal either he then
tweeted out in response and this is
where again a little bit of a
wherewithal from the president would be
Oh
a lot more useful than what he is doing
here because he says something pretty
immoral here
he says general mcchrystal got fired
that could Doug by Obama
they puts general in quotation marks and
scare quotes first of all general
McChrystal is an actual general who
served 34 years in the military under
some very trying circumstances and he
was fired by Obama because he was very
critical of Obama's strategy in
Afghanistan because said Obama wasn't
being hawkish enough in Afghanistan so
it sound like he got fired for a bad
reason but president from goes off on
him he says general McChrystal got fired
I could dug by Obama last assignment a
total bust for a big dumb mouth Hillary
lover okay which is weird Hillary hasn't
had a lover in decades but in any case
President Trump tweeting out about how
general McChrystal isn't in actual
general obviously not a great a great
look for the President of the United
States saying that he was fired like a
dog again as I've said before on the
show
president Trump loves saying that people
were fired like Doug I don't know where
he grew up where dogs were fired I've
never actually seen a dog fired it'd be
weird right you're doing a terrible job
dog you're fired but in any case
President Trump says that general
McChrystal was flared like a Doug again
the the point that I'm making here is a
broader one which is that if President
Trump wishes to win reelection he is
going to have to convince the American
people that he has actually fit for the
job as a character it's not just that
he's superior to the Democrat but now
we've actually seen him in the
presidency he said before he was elected
he could be Lincolnesque he could be
like Washington may not be the way that
he's used to working but he could kind
of grow into the office and every day he
proves on a character level that he's
not actually doing that now does that
mean does that mean that President from
can't win reelection now of course not
Democrats could win somebody radical
they could run somebody crazy the
economy could could hit could continue
to be good circumstances could continue
to benefit president Trump lots of
things could happen would it be easier
for President Trump if he could somehow
change his character yes is that going
to happen no it's not going to happen
and that raises a question for
Republicans that question was really
raised by Mitt Romney over the weekend
so Romney is the new incoming senator
from Utah and let's face a fact about
Mitt Romney it was Mitt Romney's defeats
in 2012 that I think broke the country
because Mitt Romney was maybe the most
decent guy to run for president of the
United States in
my lifetime uses clean as the driven
snow in his personal life he was a guy
who was moderate in his politics so
moderate they had been governor of
Massachusetts and well-beloved by a lot
of members of the left's we've given him
strange new respect up to the point when
he won the Republican nomination they
proceeded to destroy him slander him
call him a bad human being and then he
lost to Barack Obama in Obama's reelect
effort in 2012 and that led Republicans
to believe listen if they're going to
drag somebody like Mitt Romney through
the mud
if Romney's good character and five
bucks for the bottom a cup of coffee in
the 2012 election then why do we need a
guy of character in 2016 at all let's
just get the nastiest guy who can throw
the most punches and let's nominate that
guy well now Mitt Romney is back and he
is criticizing President Trump on a
character level and I'll explain why
what he's doing here is tactically inept
why it's tactically inept why you can
criticize president Trump's character
when President Trump says things that
are character free like putting scare
quotes around general when dealing with
Stanley McChrystal why you can say that
that when President Trump
does stuff that is bad it's bad but
that's not the same thing as what Mitt
Romney did today in the pages of the
Washington Post I'll explain in just one
second first let's talk a little bit
about how you are going to send all your
packages in the upcoming year so the
post office a great place post office
there's a lot of great services you can
mail all your stuff obviously for a
cheap fare and also there they're
relatively efficient and all that but
you know it's even more efficient
sitting at your desk and not having to
go down to the post office
stamps.com it makes that possible that's
why I use stamps calm it's why the daily
wire uses stamps calm stamps combines
all the amazing services of the US
Postal Service directly to your computer
it's the faster more convenient way to
get postage you can simply use your
computer and print official US postage
for any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send the mail
carrier picks it up no more lugging mail
to the post office no more hassles
stamps com not only saves you time it
saves you money as well
but stamps.com you get discounted
postage rates but you can't get at the
post office not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters go check out stamps calm
right now again it's gonna save you a
lot of time which means saving you a lot
of money it does for us here at the
Daily wire right now you can enjoy that
stamps com service with a special offer
it includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale start off
the new year right go to stamps calm
click on the microphone at the top of
the
page type and promo code Shapiro that is
stamps calm enter promo code Shapiro
stamps calm promo code Shapiro go check
it out right now stamps calm promo code
Shapiro okay so MIT Romney his first day
in office and what does he decide to do
write an entire op-ed about how
unpalatable President Trump is now there
are those of us in the comments Harriet
community whose job it is to actually
comment when the President does good
stuff and when the president does bad
stuff I've been using the so-called good
Trump bad front model since 2015 since
2015-2016 when President Trump was then
just candidate Trump but MIT Romney has
been highly critical of Trump throughout
he was very critical of him in 2016 he
gave a long speech about how he thought
Trump was unfit to be President of the
United States and then Trump thought
about him for Secretary of State
Patrick's Tillerson instead sort of
humiliated him publicly and then Romney
ran for Senate in Utah and took
president Trump's endorsement and now
Romney is turning back around on Trump
and smacking him directly in the grow he
has a piece today in the Washington Post
titled the president shapes public
character of the nation Trump's
character falls short now here's the
problem with what Mitt Romney is doing
here I may agree with a lot of his
points with regard to the president's
character but what he is doing is trying
essentially to force Republicans trying
to force conservatives and so now having
to choose between quote-unquote
conservatism and trumpism it's a false
choice it's a false choice he's trying
to force people to have to choose
between President Trump and conservatism
and that may have been more of a choice
in 2016 before Trump was president but
Trump is president now and Trump's given
us a lot of very conservative policies
here's what Mitt Romney writes today and
it does beg a particular question which
is whether Mitt Romney is going to try
to primary president Trump come 2020 so
Romney writes the Trump presidents he
made a deep dissent in December the
departures of defense secretary Jim
Madison White House chief of staff John
Kelly the appointment of senior persons
of lesser experienced the abandonment of
allies who fight beside us and the
president's thoughtless claim that
America has long been a sucker in world
affairs all defined his presidency doom
it is well known that Donald Trump was
not my choice for the Republican
presidential nomination after he became
the nominee I hoped his campaign would
refrain from resentment and name-calling
it did not when he won the election I
hoped you'd rise to the occasion
his early appointments were encouraging
but on balance his conduct over the past
two years particularly his actions last
month is evidence that the president
not risen to the mantle of the office it
was a pretty strong words that the
president hasn't risen to the mantle of
the office meaning basically he's still
unfit for the presidency he says it's
not that all of the president's policies
have been misguided whose right to align
u.s. corporate taxes with those of
global competitors to strip out
excessive regulations to crack down on
China's unfair trade practices to reform
criminal justice to appoint conservative
judges these are policies mainstream
Republicans have promoted for years but
policies and appointments are only part
of a presidency I'll continue by
explaining more about Mitt Romney's
perspective here in just a second and
why he's doing it in the pages of the
Washington Post and what this means for
the sort of choice that is going to be
set up falsely by Romney and by the
press in 2024 Republicans on Splenda in
just second Mitt Romney says so a great
degree a presidency shapes the public
character of the nation a president
should unite us and inspire us to follow
our better angels a president shouldn't
demonstrate the essential qualities of
honesty and integrity and elevate the
national discourse with comedy and
mutual respect as a nation we have been
blessed with presidents who have called
on the greatness of the American spirit
with the nation so divided resentful and
angry presidential leadership in
qualities of character is indispensable
and it is in this province where the
incumbents shortfall has been most
glaring then he talks about how in 2016
84 percent of people in Germany Britain
France Canada and Sweden believed the
American president would do the right
thing in world affairs one year later
that number had fallen to 16% I don't
know why he's citing that poll Obama was
terrible for foreign affairs and who
cares what the Germans have to say about
American foreign policy but Romney
continues he talks about America
abdicating leadership and then he talks
about repairing our fiscal foundation
basically this piece runt and this piece
reads like Mitt Romney is interested in
running for president again in 2020
that's what it reads like he concludes
this piece by saying I remain optimistic
about our future in an innovation age
Americans Excel
more importantly noble instincts live in
the hearts of Americans the people of
this great land will issue the politics
of the anger and fear if they are
summoned to the responsibility by
leaders in homes in churches and schools
and businesses and government who raise
our sights and respect the dignity of
every child of God the ideal that is the
essence of America so first of all I
want to argue with Romney's general
perception of the presidency I don't
think that the president really raises
the level of the American people as a
general rule I think the American people
may raise the level of the president but
the president is a guy hired to do a
particular job if you get your moral
guidance from the presidents of the
United States I would suggest that
you're looking to the wrong places if
you get your moral guidance from your
teachers from your parents from your
family from your pastor from your priest
or rabbi that seems to make a lot more
sense to me than getting your moral
guidance from Barack Obama Donald J
Trump george w bush or anybody else in
what is a public governmental office but
in any case what romney's doing here is
really counterproductive now again this
is coming from someone who's been quite
critical of president Trump's character
but not in the pages of the Washington
Post since President Trump became
president and the reason for that is
because what Romney is actually doing
now is he's setting up the possibility
of a primary run against Trump
there's been a lot of talk about this
from a certain segments of the
Republican Party and it's a big mistake
the reason that it's a big mistake is
because basically what you are now
suggesting what the media will suggest
is that a primary race between say Mitt
Romney and Donald Trump is race between
true decency and conservatism versus the
evil evil Trump guy and then when Trump
wins the primaries it'll be well look at
those deplorable Republicans they voted
for Trump over Mitt Romney look at those
terrible terrible Republicans those evil
terrible people who voted for the
incumbent president when they were given
a choice of a more decent kinder gentler
alternative when that isn't the actual
calculus okay because whoever runs
against Trump in a primary is going to
have to basically make three cases
they're gonna have to declare that they
are a person of better character than
Trump which in all plausibility will be
true probably they'll say that they'll
have to say they're a better
representative of conservatism than
Trump in 2020 which probably will not be
true in terms of policy and then they'll
have to say that they're more likely to
win in 2020 then Trump which is likely
to be false and that's gonna be the
calculus that actual Republican voters
do when they look at 2020 they're not
just gonna say in a vacuum
who would I prefer Mitt Romney or Donald
Trump they're gonna look and say Mitt
Romney walleston 2012 and Trump won in
2016 so I'm more likely to vote for the
guy who I think is gonna win Trump
they're gonna look at Mitt Romney in
2012 versus Trump in 2020 and say Trump
has a record of appointing now probably
by that point a hundred federal judges
Trump has a record of cutting
regulations from his record of
rebuilding alliances in the Middle East
President Trump has a record of criminal
justice reform and movement to the US
Embassy in Israel to Jerusalem in the
rebuilding of the
military and God willing a decent
economy there to look at all those
factors and they're gonna say I'll pick
Trump over Romney but what Romney will
have set up and have done so in the
pages of the Washington Post is this
false narrative that choosing Trump over
a Romney or John Kasich or somebody else
in the Republican Party is just
Republicans doubling down on Trump's
lack of character which is really not
what's going on here and most people
accept it in the middle of 2015 2016
what Trump was as a human being most
people certainly since then know what he
is as a human being I don't think there
are a lot of Republicans sitting around
thinking that this guy is somebody you'd
recommend to be your pastor somebody
that you recommend babysit your kids
when you go out for dinner at night but
they look at his record if you look at
the fact that he beat Hillary Clinton
and they'd be likely to vote for him in
a primary but Romney is doing here is he
is setting up a narrative that the left
will use to Club Republicans into
submission which is that if you vote for
Trump in 2020 then this is because
you're a bad person it reinforces the
deplorable theme the Democrats use to
their great advantage in 2016 I hope to
use particularly to advantage with
younger people in upcoming elections
that's bad news
and so what Romney is doing here is
strategically inept unless he believes
that Trump is going to leave office in
disgrace
in which case he's basically positioning
to be the heir apparent and to pick up
the mantle saying well I stood at the
wart Trump all these years and now I
should hand it over to me by the way the
chances of that happening are zero
Republicans are not handing over the
party to the guy who lost to Barack
Obama in his in his reelect effort in
2012 it's not going to happen the
general feeling among Republicans about
Romney is that Romney is a perfectly
serviceable nice fellow who lost to
Barack Obama and is really milquetoast
and is spending more time ripping Trump
these days than he is going after
Democrats that's the general perception
among Republicans now that's not to say
that there aren't problems with the
Republican view of Trump in certain
quarters I think there are problems for
example today Jerry Falwell did an
interview in The Washington Post that is
not great I'll explain that in just one
second but first let's talk about a
present that you should get for somebody
this new year and your for yourself
honestly but is the gift of an awesome
time piece I'm talking about a watch
that is classic and minimalist looking
I'm talking about a watch that I wear
pretty much every day the movement watch
okay and the MT watches are just
fantastic they are not designed to tell
you how many calories you
Wasser how many steps you've taken
instead they're designed to tell you the
time and to do so in a classy looking
way it looks like a really expensive
watch and instead it is a relatively
inexpensive watch this kind of watch
them cost you four or five hundred bucks
at the department store well if you get
it from MBM t.com slash shapiro right
now you can apply can hundred bucks and
these watches are just great okay I'm
all about supporting grounds up
entrepreneurs who work hard for what
they want which is why I love movement
they're a true success story and it
makes wearing their products a lot more
meaningful again these watches are all
about looking good they start at like 95
bucks you're looking at four to five
hundred bucks for the same quality at an
apartment store clean design minimal
really quality products movement has
sold almost two million watches in over
160 countries get 15% off today with
free shipping and free returns by going
to mV MT comm / apparel I love my
movement watch I've got two of them my
wife has a movement watch my mom has a
movement watch my dad has a movement
watch there's a reason I get movement
watches for everybody not just because
they're sponsored but also cuz they're
great and the MT comm / Shapiro go check
them out they're always adding new
styles MVM t-dot-com / apparel go join
the movement
MVM t comm / shapiro go check it out
right now speaking of the attempt to
paint Republicans as bad characters
Jerry Falwell Jr who is the head of
Liberty University a great institution I
love the students at Liberty you
I spoke there last year it's it's really
a fantastic fantastic place but Jerry
Falwell Jr is doing a poor job of
representing Republicans when it comes
to president Trump particularly again
playing into the narrative the
Republicans don't need so as I say going
forward to 2020 the narrative they would
benefit Republicans as president Trump
changes character barring that the
narrative that the Republicans are gonna
want to push is you may not like
president Trump's character I may think
that he's a bad character myself but is
he getting the job done so far the
answer is yes and so I'm not going to
turn over the government to radical
leftists simply to show my disdain for
president Trump's character which I've
done every day since President Trump
basically announced whatever he has done
something wrong yeah I don't have to
throw the election to Elizabeth Warren
or Kamala Harris in order to demonstrate
that I don't like president Trump's
tweeting and that is not a necessity of
American government that seems like a
better argument but unfortunately there
are Republicans like Mitt Romney who
want to make this next election a choice
between president Trump's character and
conservatism which is not an actual
choice that's not the choice that's
happening here
and then there are people like Jerry
Falwell Jr who sort of want to force the
same choice they want to suggest that
President Trump is actually a godsend in
every possible way so Jerry Falwell Jr
has this long interview in The
Washington Post when he talks about how
President Trump is just spectacular and
he was asked about whether Christians
were supposed to support nice guys he
said it's a distortion of the teachings
of Jesus to say that what he taught us
to do personally to love our neighbors
as ourselves help the poor can somehow
be imputed on the nation jesus never
told Cesar how to run Rome he went out
of his way to say that's the earthly
Kingdom I'm about the heavenly kingdom
and I'm here to teach you how to treat
others how to help others but when it
comes to serving your country you render
under Caesar that which is Caesars I
have a real problem with this basic idea
which is that like it's it's an
Augustinian idea this is the city of God
city of man distinction and it's not
quite as firm as Jerry Falwell Jr is is
making it right here which is basically
that Christians have no say in how the
nation is to be governed that render
unto Caesar what is Caesar's means that
Christians should have no care about the
character of their leaders is a very
wierd contention and then he talks about
how there's literally nothing the
President Trump could do that would
endanger his support that's an amazing
statement again in people of principle
should always say the answer is yes
there's always stuff that Trump could do
to endanger my support and he in danger
is my support every day when he picks up
when when he when he decides to do
something unpalatable right you should
feel the way about every politician by
the way even politicians that you love
politicians that you love should
endanger your support every time they go
out every day because one pretty
fundamental elements of faith is that
you should have faith in God but not man
to say that nothing President Trump
could ever do when in danger your
support to an amazing statement from a
Christian leader you know but this is
again reinforcing a narrative that the
left wants which is that it's either
total fealty to trump or conservatism
and decency that's that's a false choice
and it's not a real choice and it's not
what's really going on right here again
I think the Jerry Falwell Jr does a
disservice when he does interviews like
this and again this is this is the this
is the narrative the Democrats are going
to try to push in 2020 now the good news
for Republicans is that Democrats are
going to have a really tough time
pushing this particular narrative in
2020 because they become so radical
themselves so the narrative Democrats
were one in 2020 is the reverse
narrative of
thousand in two thousand it was two
years after the Clinton impeachment
scandal and the Monica Lewinsky stuff
and President Clinton was out of the
picture but Al Gore was now running for
the White House and George W Bush was
running on the basis of bringing
character back to the Oval Office it's
the same thing that Jimmy Carter did in
1976 when he ran against Gerald Ford
it's time for us to bring character back
to the White House that's usually a
pretty successful tack but in order to
make that claim you actually have to be
some semblance of normal and moral and
the problem for Democrats is that there
aren't too many candidates in their
ranks who are anything remotely
resembling normal and moral the latest
case in point is Elizabeth Warren so
Elizabeth Warren is because she declared
over the weekend and that she wants to
run for president which is a shock to
precisely no one she'd been sending
smoke signals from her wigwam about it
for legitimately years at this point
so she announced that she would be
running for president and then she said
she was going to build a grassroots
campaign and that she would be wandering
the plains in search of of both Buffalo
and voters here is senator very
native-american Elizabeth Warren talking
about exploring her presidential run in
front of a garage before the Boston the
assembled Boston media right now
Washington works great for the wealthy
and the well-connected it's just not
working for anyone else but I am
optimistic I believe in what we can do
together
I'm gonna build a grassroots campaign
it's already got people from all across
this country who are going to be part of
it and together we're gonna make change
and if people out there see it and want
to be part of it I hope they go to
Elizabeth Warren comm and join us
because this is how we're gonna build
the movement in she instrument she is
inspiring I mean it's like her campaign
manager went out there and said okay we
want Hillary's campaign without the name
recognition or the charisma let's do
that let's do it let's just make that
happen right there I mean it was so bad
her presidential announcement that not
only did she have to avoid a question
about her DNA and her Native American
ancestry which she did she also did she
tried to be a cool kid sure I'll show
you the cool kid thing in a second here
was Elizabeth Warren being asked about
her Native American DNA this is why the
Democrats are gonna have a little bit of
a tough time arguing character against
President
because they can't even get their own
party on board with saying it's okay to
be a particular genetic ancestry
the reason Elizabeth Warren has to
pretend to be Native American is because
she doesn't rank high enough on the
intersectionality scale for Democrats to
care about her that's what's happening
here
she's out Bernie by Bernie Sanders she's
out obama by beta O'Rourke and she is
out she's out intersectionality by
canalla Harris so she really has no path
here and she's not diverse enough she's
not radical enough like Bernie Sanders
and she's not charming enough like beta
O'Rourke and so she is kind of forced
into this weird corner where two years
ago she was a hot thing and now she's a
nothing
here's Elizabeth Warren dodging the DNA
question look I'm in this fight because
I understand what's happening to working
families I grew up in a
paycheck-to-paycheck family and my big
chance was a commuter college that cost
$50 this semester I run for office
because I'm grateful down to my toes for
the opportunities that were given to me
and I am determined that we will give
those same opportunities not just as
some of our kids but to all of them yeah
I'm sure she's gonna explode Trump out
of the water with that kind of character
and charisma I'm sure my favorite part
of her campaign is that she opened up by
then doing an Alexander Ocasio Cortes
style Instagram so AOC will call her AOC
because that's the thing now right
they've got notorious RBG we got a OC
we've got all of these these initials
political leaders but AOC does these
political instagrams where she cooks
like instant pot recipes while taking
questions from her mailbag my instant
pot recipe would basically be cereal and
milk by the way if I were to do an
Instagram like this but in any case I
love that Elizabeth Warren she's
basically the Steve Buscemi character
from Saturday Night Live how do you do
fellow kids and she's she's walking into
the Instagram and she is now doing
instant pot recipes well in her kitchen
while drinking beer I don't know if you
remember in 2016 Hillary Clinton went to
Cedar Rapids and she she had like a can
of some sort of juices I should I'm just
chilling in Cedar Rapids well here's
here's Elizabeth Warren doing that
me appeal my husband Bruce it is now I'm
here
well should we got ah Kenny is that
right Kenny and the boys stairs grandmas
Wiggin off the top right there uh yeah
that's that's gonna go regret with the
kids the kids are like oh man she's
awesome because she drinks beer she's
the best Wow
what get grandma over there taking out
her teeth and then swigging on the beer
yeah that's yeah this is gonna go great
for the Democrats we'll get to more of
the Democrats being unable to to play
the character card against President
Trump in just a second again part of
character is also a feeling of
authenticity
nothing is less authentic than that
video I mean that video is just air SATs
garbage it's it's so it's so fantastic
in pretty much every way I haven't seen
a candidate that inauthentic since
Hillary Clinton since this last time
well get to all that in just a second
first I want to talk to you about your
impending doom so I know it's the new
year and you're in a good mood because
guess what we're gonna jump back into
work and have a brand new year but you
could die this year I mean I just I
don't mean to break it to you that way
you could plot I mean you could just be
driving around tomorrow and boom your
year was two days old alright that that
could have been a thing that happened to
you but in order for you make sure that
your family is not left bereft if that
should happen to you you really should
have some life insurance getting life
insurance is one of the more
intimidating parts of becoming a
full-fledged adult but if you are into
adulting you may want to get life
insurance and you should get life
insurance because policy genius is
around policy genius have created a
website that make it easy for you to
compare quotes get advice get covered
without extra fees or Commission sales
agents policy genius is the easy way to
get life insurance in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
the coverage you need at a price you can
afford
from there you can apply online the
advisers at policy genius will handle
all the red tape they'll even negotiate
your rate with the insurance company
it's all part of their best price
guarantee and policy genius doesn't just
make life insurance easy whether you're
shopping for disability insurance to
protect your income homeowners insurance
or auto insurance they can help you get
covered fast like listen I'm sick today
and I could plot later today but I have
life insurance I was responsible
you
also be responsible you should go get
life insurance right now a policy genius
in minutes you can compare quotes and
apply I've checked out policy genes it
really is easy and user-friendly you can
do the whole thing on your phone right
now
policy genius it's the easy way to
compare it and buy life insurance go
check it out right now
policy genius.com and go check out their
life insurance possibilities in minutes
well we have a lot more coming up on
today's show because we have such a
backlog of things to talk about we have
to get to all of them but first you have
to go over today Lee Weyer calm and
subscribe so for $9.99 a month you get
the rest of this show live you get the
rest of the Michael Noel's show live I
don't know I'd want that but sure you
can have it if you want it I mean if you
also want syphilis we can give that to
you probably we can find someone here
too maybe not maybe we can't give that
to you but we can give you Michael
Noel's show you can also give you Andrew
Clavin the show live also coming up in
2019 beginning next week the Ben Shapiro
radio show will be extending to three
hours which means that we are adding two
full hours with all the great content
you have come to enjoy unless you listen
live on the radio only daily wire
subscribers will be able to get the full
three hour show on demand we're also
gonna be taking some questions during
some of the breaks and stuff so make
sure to become a daily wire subscriber
today also coming up tomorrow don't miss
our next episode of daily wire backstage
where you can watch a bunch of us dudes
some of them smoke cigars and drink
whiskey I sit there and I sip water and
smoke a bubble pipe because I don't
approve of all of this machismo but
Andrew Clavin will be there Michael
knows the execrable will be there Alicia
Krauss who is not in fact a beer
drinking beer swilling cigar smoking man
will be there as well
daily where god-king jeremy boring and
his beard will both be there and I will
be here to ring in the New Year and of
course answer your questions as always
only daily wire subscribers get to ask
the questions to make sure to subscribe
today also so many goodies to mention
today this Sunday General Stanley
McChrystal on the Sunday special he had
some things to say and you're gonna want
to hear all those things that he had to
say because he really is kind of an
interesting guy so go check that here's
what it sounded like hi I'm Stan
McChrystal join us this week on the Ben
Shapiro show for the Sunday special
we're gonna talk about politics talk
about leadership talk about my new book
leaders myth and reality and all the
kinds of things in the world that are on
our minds
okay so go check that out so many good
things happen in sure I promised I have
so many exciting plans for this year
you're gonna want to be part of this
team go to Daley we're calm
$99 a year you get all of those things
plus this the greatest in leftist year
is hot or cold tumblers now you may have
noticed that I'm ill tonight
you know why mill I was on vacation you
know what I didn't have with me on
vacation this thing right here this
leftist cheers hot or cold tumbler I was
in Hawaii and I didn't bring it with me
because when I travel I'm loathe to
bring the possibility of damage to my
precious left ear tears hot or cold
tumbler
well I protected it but it did not
protect me and thus I am sick I'm not
saying that you can protect it by all
disease and harm in life by drinking
from the leftist chairs Hydra cold
tumbler all I'm saying is that
correlation may be causation when I
didn't have the tumbler got sick when I
did have the tumbler didn't get sick I
know it's tell you go check it out right
now
$99 here you get all those things plus
the leftist here's hot Oracle tumblr
which will bring you happiness and
fulfillment in life
I know mister girl things can't but this
can may be in any case go check that out
we always appreciate your listeners
we're the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation happy
new year
[Music]
by the way if Elizabeth Warren had
actually had a drink of beer from the
leftist chairs counter cold tumbler
would made her video a lot cooler
so Elizabeth Warren gonna have a tough
time running against President Trump and
meanwhile the Democrats are busy
clubbing each other with bricks over the
2020 nomination every Democrat on planet
Earth wants to run governor jay Inslee
of Washington State who yeah I know he
wants to run there Eric SWA well who
yeah he wants to run Eric Garcetti the
horrible horrible mayor of Los Angeles
wants to run like named a Democrat and
that person probably wants to run for
president the top three candidates right
now on the Democratic side are pretty
obviously Joe Biden Bernie Sanders in
beta O'Rourke I think that'll work wins
the nomination if I had to predict it
right now he's born with the momentum
he's the only one of these guys he's
charming he's got the press behind him I
mentioned before the break that I think
that beta O'Rourke is the only candidate
who has the possibility of sort of
unifying the various parts of the
Democratic Party but the problem for the
Democrats is that while they are running
on character issues against President
Trump politics sometimes betrays
character and when the Democrats go so
radical on politics that they seem
wildly out of kilter and off base when
they seem like they are not in touch
with the American people people take
that as a character critique too and so
it doesn't help them when their top
politicians are saying things about
climate change like it's a Bernie
Sanders the the socialist loon bag from
Vermont he tweeted out the other day we
must look at climate change as it was
devastating military attack against the
United States and the entire planet we
must respond accordingly well I mean if
Bernie Sanders has oh I guess that means
that we would surrender if there were
devastating military attack against the
United States
I guess Bernie Sanders the stake would
be that we should surrender to global
warming but in any case this is if the
Democratic pitch is president Trump is
immoral we have to treat it being hotter
outside the same way that we would treat
a military attack by nuking the power
plants like session the Sun not sure
what he's recommending there that's
gonna be a bit of a hard pitch he's not
the only one saying this this is the new
democratic pitch their moral case their
political moral case is that President
Trump is not just a man of little
character which again I think is a case
that can be made the case that they are
going
try and make is that President Trump is
immoral in his politics and the way
they've been making that case has been
really awkward because they've been
making the case that he's immoral
because he wants a wall which is
patently not immoral in fact it's a good
idea to have some sort of border barrier
to prevent people from illegally
immigrating into the United States and
now they're trying to make the case the
president Trump is almost a Hitlerian
character because he doesn't care enough
about climate change an issue about
which most Americans don't care Jerry
Brown our senile Governor of California
who's been governor since approximately
1833 legitimately he's now one thousand
two hundred and eleven years old it's
really amazing so Jerry Brown is
doddering around here in my home state
and he says that climate change is as
devastating as the Nazis to humanity
which comes as a shock to my people I
like no not much like it was it was uh
it's been hot outside but it was a lot
hotter in certain situations for Jews in
the past here is Jerry Brown from
California making the place that climate
change it's just the fact that it took
Roosevelt many many years to get America
willing to go into World War Two and
fight the Nazis well we have an enemy
though different but perhaps very much
devastating in a similar way and we got
to fight climate change and the
president's got a lead on that okay so
it's just like Roosevelt mobilizing
America for World War two is just like
the president mobilizing America to
fight global warming if this is the
moral case the Democrats are going to
make they're gonna have a tough times
here here's the thing in the late 90s
Americans basically came to the
conclusion that you could divorce
character in politics then President
Clinton's character and his politics
were completely separable he could get
good policy out of a guy who's bad
person and most Americans basically
learned to agree with that because then
we got a good character in the President
George HW Bush who most Democrats
decided was evil on policies he had a
what Democrats decided a bad character
with good politics Bill Clinton and then
a good character with bad politics
George W Bush and then the view of
Democrats a good character with good
politics in Barack Obama and then a bad
character of bad politics in President
Trump right that's the view of Democrats
on the various presidents that we've had
over the past once here's what that
means the character and politics are
separable
well if character and politics are
separable then Donald Trump can be a bad
character and also be a pretty good
president
but according to Democrats they have to
make the case that he's also a bad
character on politics and the salad if
the most solid case they have is that he
is not intersectional enough or that he
doesn't pay enough attention to climate
change or that he is insufficiently
insufficiently kind to illegal
immigrants that's gonna be a bit of a
tough case ok meanwhile I have already
dubbed what this year is going to be so
I think that the year 2019 is going to
be the year of the wokes cold ok not
wokes gold woke skulls so we now live in
an era in which the left insists and
this is where the radicalism of the left
really comes to the fore and cultural
and political terms that that we rewrite
biology language religion politics art
all of these things must be rewritten so
that we all stay woke and if you if you
refuse to abide by these new moral
strictures of the left then this makes
you immoral
this is why so many people have reacted
to president rums character failings and
said ok whatever at least you're not at
least he's not trying to tell me what to
say or what to do you guys are trying to
tell me what to say and what to do
you're the new Puritans except the
Puritans actually we're trying to
promulgate some decent social policy
once in a while and the the latest
indicator that the left has gone too far
in the woke scolding has been louis c.k
so Louie CK before his downfall
was probably my favorite working
comedian and that is saying that despite
the fact that louis c.k is a wild
leftist who hated Sarah Palin is vulgar
is vile as a human being he's really
really funny his if you ever want to
watch a great comedy set go watch louis
c.k talk about what it is like to raise
children who asked him any questions
it's really really good his Lucy Kay is
a very talented comedian well if you
recall last year louis c.k was out in
the middle of the me2 scans in the Miche
movement for having basically brought
back female comedians to his greenroom
and then having pushed them to watch him
perform sexual acts upon himself right
this was this and he he went into
self-imposed exile and lost tens of
millions of dollars in all of the rest
well now he's coming back well the
Wilkes Gold's don't want him to come
back they say that he has he has sinned
he can never return to public life I
mean this is the amazing thing
about the new woke scolding sjw's is
that there's no such thing as repentance
there's no such thing as redemption if
you sin against them then you must be
cast out into the nether regions forever
unless you are sufficiently wildly
leftist like Kathy Griffin then then
maybe you get to come back in any case
louis c.k who is indeed a wild leftist
was never supposed to come back but now
he is coming back and he did a comedy
set the other night and in this comedy
set he made some jokes now Louis CK's
brand of comedy has always been
transgressive and we were told by the
left four years the transgressive comedy
was a social good by George Carlin
social good Richard Pryor social good
blue comedy great right all of these
violated barriers violated taboos were
good for society because they awakened
us to our own excesses and hypocrisy and
well Louie CK comes back and he does a
couple of jokes and he tells a joke
about Auschwitz and he tells a joke
about parkland survivors and then he
tells a joke about gender fluidity
here's a little bit of his set and the
left went nuts on him because apparently
louis ck's brand of humor is no longer
acceptable in woke scold world and see
people in their 20s and be like they're
crazy these kids are just you shouldn't
dress me like royalty they tell you what
to call them you shouldn't trust me
and pay them because I identified gender
neutral you should be crazy
you should be unhinged not in a suit
saying I'm here to tell you interesting
because you went to a high school where
kids got shots what does that mean I
have a listen to you
interesting okay so everybody's going
crazy how dare he make these jokes well
cuz he's a comedian that's what he does
are the jokes taboo and transgressive
yes that's his whole shtick go back and
watch his comedy routine three four
years ago
it's probably probably not six to ten
years ago in which he talks about but
where he says of course but maybe it's a
great comedy routine where he talks
about all these things that we now
consider deeply immoral but maybe
they're not ready to-- of course of
course
we should make sure that kids who have
peanut allergies are never exposed to
peanuts but maybe if we just let them
all be exposed to peanuts then peanut
allergies will be a thing of the past in
one generation right he's been doing
this sort of transgressive comedy his
entire career the left has decided he
must be scolded out of existence well
and then they say we have to redefine
comedy where Louie CK is no longer funny
but you know who's seriously funny
Samantha bee Samantha bee and Hannah
Gadsby the best kind of comedy is the
comedy where you don't laugh ever see
what we've been doing wrong all these
years is to finding comedy as funny
things when in reality the only thing
that's funny is that we ever considered
comedy funny at one time the real comedy
is you being lectured and why you aren't
enough of a woke person to make those
kind of jokes that's real comedy true
comedy is that if this is the way that
the left wants to promulgate culture
they are going to lose okay this is the
this is the real downfall of bluff they
can attack president Trump's character
as much as they want but if I have a
choice between listening to the dopes
who think that louis c.k shouldn't be
able to make a taboo joke and Donald
Trump tweeting like a from the
White House this is not a choice for me
this is a very easy choice for me if
that's my only choice right if it's just
a black/white one or the other choice I
don't think I should have to choose
either but if you want to choose one or
the other you think I'm gonna turn over
the country to people who think that
louis c.k should be forced to tell
knock-knock jokes you think i'm gonna
turn over the country to a bunch of
people who say the Louie CK's jokes now
are deeply inappropriate when ten years
ago the same people were cheering them
on when he was like ripping into Sarah
Palin and calling her a c-word sorry not
gonna buy II think I'm gonna turn over
the country to a bunch of people who
have to cancel their own marches because
they're not intersectional enough in
Northern California there was a women's
March and the women's march in Northern
California had to be canceled because it
was too white I'm not kidding you they
actually canceled their
women's marks because they said there
were not enough black people in it this
according to the it's any vain Stein of
the of the San Francisco Chronicle
Northern California women's March
canceled for being overwhelmingly
White's they said the decision came
after organizers and supporters of the
movement noticed participants over the
years had been overwhelmingly white in
lieu of the March which was originally
set to take place on January 19th
organizers will discuss a way to broaden
cultural representation going forward
the committee wrote in a statement
instead of pushing forward with crucial
voices absent the organizing team will
take more time for outreach if I'm gonna
turn over the country to a bunch of
people who think that you can't do a
march if people aren't of the right
color like that that sounds great to me
and the turn over to the Women's Mart
the anti-semetic women's marchers who
won't March unless there are more black
people and the people who think that
louis c.k is terrible and that kevin
hart is terrible he'll come for Bill
burr next you know they're coming for
Bill burr next right they'll come after
joe rogan everybody find funny or
interesting will eventually be destroyed
by the woke skulls and that's what this
year is gonna be and president Trump
should only be hoping and praying that
if that actually happens then it will
propel him to victory again in 2020
because the reaction to cultural woke
scolding is people in politics saying
you know what I'm not gonna be scolded
by these people I'm just gonna vote for
whomever is most likely to break things
that's where that's where this is going
then the people woke it's really funny
the people on the left think that
Elizabeth Warren running for president
is what's going to stop President Trump
or Bernie Sanders or paid o'rourke what
they don't understand is the thing most
likely to propel Trump back to the
presidency in 2020 is not a race against
to any of these people it's gonna be all
of the morons on Twitter and all the
morons on Facebook and all the idiots in
the media who think that louis c.k has
to be scolded into subservience and
obedience for telling jokes about
Auschwitz or something like that that's
what's driving people up a wall okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like this week so there's a a guy really
really talented artist named Mike Miller
and he was the lead artist on the
injustice series from DC Comics well now
he's gone independent and he has a new
project called Lone Star heart of the
hero and it's really worth checking out
and go check out his IndieGoGo what's
really cool is that when you do his kind
of upper level IndieGoGo fundraising you
can actually send copies of this new
comic
star to the Troops you can send some a
minimum of five copies to troops around
the world via the US so go check them
out right now in indiegogo.com here's a
little bit of the art it's just
beautiful I'd go check out lone Starr
from Mike Miller
[Applause]
[Music]
so it's kind of like 80s style and it's
also the art of it is really cool you
should go check out the art of it's
really beautiful it's it's fun to read
so check it out loans start heart of the
hero and if you want to give some copies
to the troops then you can go check that
out at indiegogo.com slash projects Lone
Star that that's that's something worth
checking out okay other things that I
like I would be remiss if I did not
mention president Trump's Christmas so
President Trump had himself a merry
little Christmas and I will admit that I
sent this clip to probably 15 people on
Christmas Eve wishing them Merry
Christmas
why because President Trump did phone
calls with a bunch of kids who called
into the White House and one of these
kids was a seven year old girl and
President Trump asked the 7 year old
girl if she still believes in Santa
Claus here he was it was great okay so
first of all yes yes so first it's great
owning the owning the libs with
certitude and confidence president from
owning the seven-year-old libs you still
believe in Santa Claus and that's that
is just spectacular stuff do you still
believe in Santa Claus are you stupid
[Laughter]
seven-year-old it's kind of blurry Lloyd
Wright like what happens if she's like
yeah I still believe in Santa Claus like
oh okay I'll just back away snow day all
right we're your parents pretty
spectacular so now I will admit that I
have been in the President Trump side of
that phone call before right I've done
that to people like I did that when I
was I think for like it is he in the
Jewish community we don't do the
Christmas which means we also don't do
the Santa and there was a girl who lived
across the street named Colleen and I
was friends with her and she was a nice
Christian girl and she and I were the
same age we're probably both three or
four years old and she came over to my
house and she was talking about how
Santa was gonna bring her lots of
presents for Christmas and I said to her
Santa's not real and her mom got super
pissed and called my parents and wanted
to know why I had said that my parents
were like well is Santa real and she's
like no but you're not supposed to tell
kids that like what we didn't do it was
our kid in any case I did that when I
was four I wasn't 73 when I did that to
a seven-year-old but you gotta love it
President Trump I mean that that is some
ownership of the libs right there that's
why we elected him we liked it and no
one really expected it right cuz he had
ended the war on Christmas the president
and the president had fought against
those assaulting Christmas no one
expected him like no one expected him to
simply swivel and then blitzkrieg
Christmas that way right like he he'd
already end of the war and then suddenly
he decided to launch his own offensive
on Christmas was really incredible so
well done President Trump for for what
was a studly display of of owning with
facts and knowledge okay time for some
things that I hate
so I only knowledge I hate New Year's
celebrations I think New Year
celebrations because I'm a killjoy and
also because they suck so have you ever
been to a New Year's party we were like
yeah that was totally worth it
so my wife and I were in Times Square
probably now seven or eight years ago
and we had gone to a musical and then we
were gonna stay in Times Square and we
decided this is probably the most
miserable place to be on New Year's Eve
just packed in in this claustrophobic
place where if five people turn around
and start a stampede a hundred thousand
people die this is this a bad idea you
know staying up to watch the the ball
drop on New Year's Eve is no fun and you
can tell when people are sort of forced
to have fun right it's what we at the
office like to call mandatory fun like a
Christmas party mandatory fun right is
is sort of what everybody has on New
Year's Eve it's like well it's New
Year's Eve you're supposed to have fun
it's all you have to do and so the media
members decide that they are going to
force you to engage in the fun along
with them and this means that we're
going to watch news anchors act like
morons one of the things I find
hilarious about this is we have gotten
non-stop virtue signaling from the media
all day long all day long all year long
for years now about how the United
States is now a dangerous place for
members of the news media let me ask you
a question when you watch those
broadcasts on New Year's Eve a members
of the news media getting drunk and
talking about their sex lives did this
seem to you like a wildly dangerous
place for members of the news media it
didn't to me why are we having on random
celebrities who are less relevant in
1973 to talk about the countdown to 2019
no one knows but here was NBC talking
about steaming of the genitals on their
New Year's Eve countdown show because
this is solid TV mandatory fun guys
Chrissy Teigen talking about steaming
her genitals
I mean I guess it's better than dry
cleaning down there but in any case uh
like what like this is on the New Year's
Eve there are kids who actually watch
this stuff and yet that was the thing
that was those happening that wasn't the
only thing that was happening on the
networks CNN's Anderson Cooper decided
to talk about his mom's sex life on-air
he talked about one time when his mom
nailed Marlon Brando which I mean
honestly is no shock apparently Richard
Pryor also knit nailed Marlon Brando
which is which is more of a shocker by
Richard Pryor Marlon Brando like the
villain from Superman 3 and Superman's
dad getting it on in like 1979 things
are weird in any case here was here was
Anderson Cooper talking about his mom's
sex life on CNN don't worry these are
respected members of the media stop it
they are journalism these are
journalists take them seriously they
must be taken seriously here's Anderson
Cooper who I guess we're supposed to
take seriously with hot Marla Brenda not
like Apocalypse Now Marlon Brando yeah
she hooked up with like I think it was
on the waterfront Marlon Brando Wow
she she and Carole Matthau both watched
the movie and both made a deal that they
were gonna meet up ok well that's how
he's good stuff is when you're talking
about your mom's sex life on national TV
I can't imagine if that affected
Anderson Cooper is a child or anything
in any case very very wet and then CNN's
Randi Kaye another great reporter is
drinking champagne from a bomb live on
New Year's Eve these are journalists who
are very much in danger remember
President Trump hasn't changed their
lives President Trump has
single-handedly put their lives in
danger they are so afraid that they are
out at public bars drinking from
champagne bongs on New Year's Eve on
most populous night of the of the year I
mean look look at the date this is true
journalism here we go
all right this is not a good idea not a
good idea
okay and it turns out that the worst
move the worst move of the night came
courtesy of Siena's well Jane Curtin I
guess it's some sort of commentator for
CNN she came on CNN don't know who she
is or which crypt she crawled out of but
she says that she has a new year's
resolution to ensure the GOP dies great
fantastic stuff guys wow that's that's
so funny that's like amazing Wow
so she's a comedian sometimes I guess
she was referred to as the queen of
deadpan and was included in a 1986 list
of the top primetime actors and
actresses of all time awesome Thank You
Wikipedia so yeah the media doing and
doing yeoman's work each and every day
to remind us why they are in the
positions that they are but we're
supposed to take them seriously but
we're not supposed to take president
Trump seriously because they're serious
people and Trump is not a serious person
okay
well we'll be back here tomorrow now let
me remind you it is a brand new year
it's gonna be a long year it's gonna be
a hard slog we're gonna be here with you
every step of the way we're gonna be
enjoying having fun breaking it all down
for you and we can't wait to do it cuz
it gonna be a blast see you tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this adventure Pierrot
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing